Okay. There are people very eager to get on
and ask some questions. Uh, the phone number
is (617) 830-4750 let's start today with our
caller from the eight oh six area code. Who's
calling today from eight zero six
Hey David, how are you?
Good. Who's this?
This is David Corona. I'm actually located
in no El Paso.
Really? Okay. Well interesting to hear from
you. What's going on?
Hey, so do you think now after these unfortunate
mass shooting here, do you think Republicans,
well now that they have more pressure to pass
a, to centralize the background checks, do
you think that Mitch McConnell will come back
and pass a clean bill or you think they're
going to try to tie it to an immigration bill
that Trump wants to?
We're already seeing that the idea floated
of tying it to an immigration bill, which
I think is is disgusting and wrong headed.
Um, we, I've seen that it, it seems as though
Republicans are sort of coming around on the
idea of these red flag laws, which are quite
frankly, I mean there's just so much more
that needs to be done, but I do generally
agree with you that it seems that the pressure
at this point is getting to the point where
they'll have to do something. It may end up
getting them more of what they want on immigration
though if they successfully tie it. So, I
mean it's just a complete and total mess,
quite frankly. David,
I agree. I think they are going to try to
tie it to an immigration unfortunate probably
will not pass I m
what's happening locally there in El Paso?
Like what's the local conversation about gun
laws that that's happening now in the wake
of what? Of the shooting.
Everyone's on board that we need to, to centralize
that background, we need to have more thorough
background check. Whether it kind of make
it more like the, like the uh, getting your
concealed where you have to go through a class,
you have to renew, you have to, you know,
of course not be a felon as you changing into
renew. Um, I think that's what, as all who
I talked to, that's what they are on board
and want to do. Even Republican.
That's what I was going to say. Can you, can
you say, or do you know whether Republicans
also want that in El Paso?
Oh yeah. I've talked to one yesterday. He
was onboard with background checks and uh,
he, he's, he was definitely on board to do
that, to do pass a clean bill. But unfortunately
he, he, he watches Fox News and he was trying
to say, well, it's Democrats always go too
far and try to do like a weapons ban, but
we know from the past there's always been
clean bills to try to pass a background checks
and it's always just that in the Senate.
Yeah. Hey, let me ask you this. You mentioned
talking to a Republican in El Paso who watches
Fox News. Is that Republican aware of what
was in the shooter's manifesto or has that
information not even gotten to him?
I didn't ask. The reason. The reason why is
because he's a, he's a a coworker and he's
a supervisor at that, so I didn't want to
be confrontational. I believe he is one that
will be confrontational, have seen them before,
but I wanted to kind of get his idea what
he thought about it and what he was on board
with changing and so he's on board with that
more thorough background checks.
Okay. Yeah, I mean that's not surprising and
that's one of those things where after the
sandy hook shooting, there was like 88 or
85% support for that and you know, it still
didn't get done. So it's actually not that
surprising. It seems a lot of Republicans
see that as a relatively minor infringement
that they would be sort of happy to accept
if not that much more is done. You know what
I mean?
Exactly. Yeah, exactly.
All right. David, really appreciate your call.
Are you going to go on Joe Road anytime soon?
I also wrote it on June 5th did you see it?
Yeah, I did. I loved it.
Are you saying am I going to be back on?
Yeah, you're going to go back on anytime?
I would love to, but there's nothing scheduled
right now.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Good. All right. Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Okay, thanks David. Yep. Best of luck down
in [inaudible]. Thank you. I appreciate that.